that's right folks as a native of
Seattle I was enjoying the Superbowl and
I was enjoying the biggest Superbowl
comeback of the decade followed shortly
by the biggest Superbowl toke of the
century seriously it was beast out eat
burgers legs you go into cardiac arrest
why not run it Ford's or whatever but in
it being just a game which it absolutely
is I was like all right I got things to
do I got videos to bring the baby or at
least video because there were Super
Bowl trailers but really one just jumped
out at me the rest Terminator Genisys
didn't show us anything new tomorrow
lands based on a Disney ride we'll see
it definitely wasn't a Batman V Superman
trailer I'd be talking about that [ __ ]
right now
Jurassic world was the one I was like I
got enough there to talk about this
trailer is full of information you knew
and then it's like oh [ __ ] Chris Pratt
is actually training the dinosaurs he's
training the velociraptors what really
that's when I started to pull back it I
was like this movie might be losing me
training to me is like alright very good
envira Chris Pratt in this movie I take
one look at Siegfried and Roy and be
like I don't think training always works
out something tells me if a Velociraptor
snaps on you it's gonna be a little
worse than a lion then big genetic evil
hybrid dinosaur I'm gonna call it the
holy [ __ ] of Soros I know it has a name
I like holy [ __ ] a Soros holy [ __ ] a
Soros really just gets right to the
point so holy [ __ ] a source starts
coming out to me but he snatches a dude
up you know he's dude munching on his
head everyone's running pterodactyls are
picking people libraries get the field
win it all goes to [ __ ] in this one
everyone's trapped on the park so you
got to think something took out the
boats probably holy [ __ ] a Soros Chris
Pratt's like we got to go after it with
everything we got
she doesn't ride his motorcycle but the
velociraptors and you're like all right
the training thing already made me pull
back here's the plot of this movie
there's a guy who trains velociraptors
then you have this genetically spliced
super dinosaur that gets loose in the
park so Siegfried of Velociraptor has to
go after holy [ __ ] a source with
everything he's got which includes an
army of velociraptors while he's riding
a motorcycle I'm gonna lie I love
Jurassic Park because of the magic of
Jurassic Park next two movies I don't
give a [ __ ] about because you feel like
they were just desperate attempts to
make it bigger than the last movie which
is what I feel this movie was the first
trailer I was like oh that might be cool
because it looks like it might recapture
some of the magic of the first movie but
after this trailer I really feel like
the pitch to this movie was like - what
do you want to do recapture the magic of
the first Jurassic Park movie do you
want to make a Jurassic Park movie
that's bigger than the third movie that
that second one a segment sounds good
just a perfect answer going to make so
much money
that's where I feel like we are it's
like Jurassic Park 3 because you have
this bigger super dinosaur that's bigger
than the t-rex like holy [ __ ] a Soros
meets the ghost in the darkness because
in this movie the holy [ __ ] of Soros is
killing for sports like it's killing for
sport which could be cool but that's
what velociraptors did right you like
hunting they didn't necessarily you they
just killed you because it was
tactically relevant I don't know that's
actually kind of the beauty of trailers
I can speculate all I want we can all
speculate all we want but in the end we
won't know until we watch the movie
hopefully this is one of those movies
like hey Jeremy that's why we make
movies and you don't I would love that
whenever I'm not impressed with the
trailer I love being wrong side like
liking movies I would love a new
Jurassic Park movie that's good that's
right now
so the Jurassic world super bowl trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it you're looking forward to this
movie like yeah I want to see holy [ __ ]
of stores kill things for fun are you
with me where you're like I don't know
about that whatever you think comment
below let me know and just let you guys
know I'm gonna be down in LA from
Tuesday the 3rd through Friday the 6
there's gonna be a lack of new content
on my channel in that you four-day
stretch I won't be able to get you my
review of Eddie Redmayne harvesting the
earth with whis personal until that
Saturday the Batman V Superman trailer
drops in that time they'll talk about it
when I get back that's when I hope it
doesn't but you know it's going to
that's just Murphy's Law patience
patience I will be back and then I will
talk about all the [ __ ] I missed and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more